Buddha finds his enlightenment under a
tree.
It's not fluke that that's the case.
That's his natural environment and he's
sitting in the Lotus here.
The Lotus opens up.
It's this thing that springs up from the
depths and he sits there illuminated the
same way.
He's got a halo that's the sun that
stands for higher consciousness and
he's.
He's transcended by accepting the fact
that life is suffering.
He's transcended the limitations that
are part of mortality.
You see that symbol there,
that swastika.
You see it there.
It's reversed.
The Nazis reversed it.
Well,
think about that mean they weren't
stupid.
If symbolism there symbols had meaning
is what this was,
were represented was what this
represents reversed.
Well,
that's a very bad idea.
This is the thing that this,
this idea is what enables people to
transcend their suffering,
and Buddha said,
well,
don't,
don't be too attached to things,
and what does that mean?
It doesn't mean deny the world.
It might mean deny the world.
If you're too in love with the material,
like with material wellbeing,
let's say.
Then your pathway to transcendence and
meaning might be to abandon that because
it's constraining you.
It's making you less than you could be,
but the fundamental lesson,
the more fundamental lesson that's
underneath that is don't let what you
are stopped you from being what you
could be.
Right,
and so then the question is,
well,
what do you identify with?
Do you identify with what you are?
Then you're a tyrant.
Do you identify with with chaos,
because that's the opposite of order.
Say then you're nihilistic ball.
You don't identify with either of those.
You know that they're both necessary.
You know that you have to live with both
of them,
but you would.
You identify with the capacity to
continually transcend what you are and
then you seek out error.
That's what humility is.
It's like I'm an error ridden psych,
so I want to see.
I want to put myself in a situation
where I can discover one of my errors.
Hopefully not in a way that's going to
knock me completely out of the game,
right?
I,
I wanna.
I want to seek out a challenge.
I want to find out where my limits are,
I want to find out where there's not
enough of me yet and I want to do it
that in a way that's engaging because
you know you can wear yourself out
fighting dragons,
so obviously you can exhaust yourself
completely and that's not helpful.
You know,
one,
one of the things I learned,
for example,
when I was coaching,
when I was coaching lawyers who these
were people who had very high end
careers and so they had an infinite
workload,
no matter how much they worked flat out
there was always way more work that they
should do.
It's very difficult thing to learn to
manage and so they were exhausting
themselves and I said,
well,
you know,
you have to work less per day.
It's like,
well no,
that's not happening.
I can't do that.
And so what I learned over time was,
okay,
so this is what you have to do every
three months.
You have to block off four days and go
have a vacation,
and you have to plan that in advance.
So it's in your calendar so that your
secretary doesn't book your time and
then you need that because you have to
recuperate enough so that you can work
as hard as you're going to work.
And of course they were nervous about
that and I said,
well look,
we can.
We can calibrate this.
Let's keep track of your billable hours
over the next year and see if they
increase or decrease because I bet you
if you take more time off,
you'll actually have more billable
hours.
You'll actually have your cake and eat
it too.
You'll get to have a vacation and you'll
be more productive and that inevitably
that was what happened.
And so that's a matter of calibrating
the game properly.
Right?
You want to play a game that you can
play today,
but also one that you can play next week
and next month.
We're not talking about,
you know,
your,
your career.
This week we're talking about you having
a career that lasts 30 years,
that doesn't kill you,
that doesn't make you hate yourself or
the job that doesn't make you better.
That doesn't where you to a frazzle.
So it has to be optimized and so I think
that you can in fact decide to take on
the load that's optimally meaningful if
you want,
and then you get to have your cake and
eat it too.
You're on the pathway to continual
incremental improvement.
You only have to burn off a feather at a
time instead of having the whole bloody
thing burst into flames.
But it's a constant.
It's a constant source of renewal and
there's an idea that to be renewed you
have to drink the water of life,
right?
That that's an old mythological idea.
And what's the water?
The water of life.
Chaos is water,
water,
water is chaos.
Water is what washes away.
Too much order.
And to stay continually,
let's say a refreshed by the water of
life is to take on exactly the right
amount of chaos to make sure that your
garden is properly nourished and I think
meaning is actually the marker of that.
And,
and as I said,
you know that I'm not,
I wouldn't consider myself either naive
or particularly optimistic person.
I don't think I'm either of those,
but this is an actually an idea.
This is one of the only ideas that I've
ever found that I really believe to be
rock solid.
I actually think that it's true and it's
very optimistic because it says you can
use your sense of meaning to calibrate
your progress through life,
but,
but there's rules.
You have to aim at the highest possible
good that you can conceive now and
that's subject to update because what
the hell you know,
but you start by aiming at the star you
can see rather than the dimmer one that
you can't yet perceive,
and then you decide that you're going to
do that honestly.
Right?
There's that.
That's a big decision.
So the first decision,
I think in some senses that decision of
love,
you're going to decide that being is
worthwhile and that you're going to work
for its betterment and that's a decision
that's based on love.
And the second decision is based on
truth.
Having made that decision,
you're going to play a straight game.
Having made those two decisions,
I think that you can allow your sense of
meaning to calibrate your pathway and
then what's so interesting is that you
hit a state that's as close to paradise
as you're going to hit right away.
Because being engaged like that,
it's better to be engaged in the
solution of a complex problem that not
to have a problem at all.
And that's no different than saying it's
better for there to be being the non
being because being is a problem.
And so if you want to have no problems,
then you have no being and and you could
say,
well,
being so miserable that maybe that's the
route we should take and fair enough,
but maybe you can have your cake and eat
it too.
You can have the damn problem.
It can be a problem we're solving and
you can be so engaged in solving the
problem that it justifies the fact that
the problem exists and then you get.
Then you get to have.
You get to have the problem and the
solution at the same time.
And maybe that's better than not having
the problem at all.
And I believe that because one of the
things I have seen,
and I've seen this so interesting being
so interesting when I've been lecturing
to people especially more recently,
and this is also manifested itself on
Youtube.
I'm talking to people a lot about
responsibility and it's young men in
particular that seem to be responding to
that and I think that's partly because I
think that young women in some sense
have their responsibility map already
laid out for them.
It's also less voluntary in some sense
for women because they have more
complicated problems to solve in the
first part of their life,
right?
Take because they have to get the family
problem solved.
But whatever.
I've been talking very in a very
delineated matter about responsibility,
which is a strange thing to sell to
people,
but responsibility is what gives your
life meaning and so then you might say,
well then take ultimate responsibility
and what happens?
You have an ultimately meaningful life.
Then you might say,
well,
if your life is ultimately meaningful,
it doesn't matter if it's punctuated by
tragedy or even predicated on tragedy.
It's worth it.
And I think that's true,
and it,
everything I've seen indicates to me
that's true.
Every time I get my clients to take on
more responsibility,
you know,
and it isn't an injunction.
You're a bad person.
You should take on responsibility.
It has nothing to do with that.
You can define the damn responsibility.
It isn't something that someone else
should impose on you.
It's not a matter of doing what you
should do in some abstract manner.
It's not that it's the choice of what
game you're going to play and you know
you can play the game of the seeker,
I would say.
And if you play that game,
then everyone wins and it's the best
game you can play.
And so the,
the,
the answer in some sense to the tragedy
of life,
to the catastrophe of life to the fall,
is to adopt the responsibility of
mortality that goes along with that and
to play that game maximally.
And paradoxically,
it's in the willingness to do that,
that the solution emerges.